this is crazy cake boss star buddy
valastro
was hospitalized after getting hurt in
the most bizarre and horrifying accident
and here's the thing
you will not believe where it happened
i had a really bad accident the other
day at my house from my hand
that may be an understatement but he
delivered a message to fans from his
hospital bed
his right hand heavily bandaged e.t has
learned but he's lucky to still have
that hand at all
bowling is a way of life the gruesome
accident happened sunday inside the
bowling alley
at buddy's new jersey home the cake boss
was trying to fix the pin setter when
his right hand became
lodged and compressed inside the unit a
rep tells e.t
buddy was repeatedly impaled by a metal
rod for over five minutes until
his teenage sons used a saw to free
their dad
he's in shock the 43 year old was rushed
into emergency surgery
he had two procedures and quote it will
be an uphill battle
as its buddy's dominant right hand and
he will need prolonged recovery and
therapy
the cake box how you doing how are you
e.t
seen how hands-on buddy is with his
estimated 10 million dollar baking
empire
celebs love his cakes now it's unclear
how his injury will impact his business
and tv projects
but the reality star is staying upbeat
getting the best care possible
and i just want to thank you for the
love and support and
we're going to get through this love you
you